[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers hallo
und guten Abend in allen wenn eine
Regierung an ihre Bürgerinnen und Bürger
appelliert sie mögen doch bitte ruhig
bleiben und normal weiterleben man könne
die Sicherheit garantieren dann kann man
davon ausgehen dass die Situation hoch
brisant ist der Nervenkrieg und das
chinesische Säbelrasseln rund um Taiwan
gehen weiter und haben heute eine neue
Eskalationsstufe erreicht china hat eine
Reihe von Gesprächen mit den USA unter
anderem über den Klimaschutz ausgesetzt
Nancy pillowcy die politische Nummer
drei der USA deren Besuch in Taiwan die
Machthaber in Peking verhindern wollten
steht jetzt auf einer chinesischen
Sanktionsliste ultra berichtet
mitten in chinas Hauptstadt Peking
feiern sie auf riesigen Videowänden die
Schlagkraft der chinesischen Armee da
ist die Bedrohung Taiwans eine
patriotische Pflicht viele wollen mit
Ausländern darüber nicht reden aber es
gibt Angst vor einem Krieg und vor den
USA ich spüre Amerika und pelos sie
haben böse Absichten
ich hoffe dass das Problem friedlich
gelöst werden kann dass niemand einen
Krieg will
China lässt Raketen sprechen verhängt
Sanktionen fliegt noch rund 20 km von
Taiwans Küste mit Kampfjets vorbei
aber dort scheinen sie irgendwie
gelassen zu sein Taiwans Bürger haben
gelernt mit der Gefahr zu leben
im Fernsehen laufen die Nachrichten von
den Militärübungen und der um zehnung
Taiwans in Archis nudelladen lassen Sie
es sich trotzdem schmecken seit
Jahrzehnten trout China den Menschen mit
Zwangsvereinigung
ich mache mir eigentlich keine Sorgen
einzige Sorge ist dass sie später
vielleicht einmal angreifen
ich habe keine Angst China traut sich
doch nicht warum die USA helfen uns doch
solche Worte verletzen die chinesischen
Nationalisten in den sozialen Medien
äußern sie sich wütend sie beschweren
sich das Pekings Machthaber Taiwan nicht
angreifen
sie haben doch gesagt sie wollen ein
Krieg anfangen aber sie machen das nicht
das ist so peinlich
Wiedervereinigung ist nur ein Lehrer
Satz wir wurden alle angelogen es gibt
keine Wiedervereinigung
Präsident Ski hat in den letzten Jahren
eine nationale Welle erzeugt die droht
ihn nun als schwach aussehen zu lassen
das will er verhindern sie manan ist ein
treuer Soldat der Partei und ein
Internet-Star 30 Millionen Chinesen
hängen an seinen Lippen in den sozialen
Medien wir treffen ihn wieder ist Chinas
Reaktion schwach fragen wir
ich hoffe dass die westlichen Kritiker
den Weitblick haben und die historischen
Realitäten akzeptieren nämlich Chinas
Stärke
er nimmt diese Drohungen sehr ernst der
Künstler Casey Wong ist vor den Chinesen
aus Hongkong geflohen heute lebt er in
Taiwan Taiwan sagt der uns ist nach
Hongkong die neue Frontlinie um die
Freiheit zu verteidigen er warnt die
Gefahr zu unterschätzen
wir haben heute zwei Systeme die sich
aggressiv ausbreiten
das eine ist Russland das andere China
wir müssen zusammenhalten um uns zu
schützen sonst machen sie uns fertig
einen nach dem anderen
noch badet chinas Führung sein Volk in
Patriotismus noch lässt sie die Armee
nur auf den Leinwänden marschieren
bringen wir unsere Korrespondenten mit
dazu zunächst Ulf Roller in Peking Ulf
guten Abend ist denn abzuschätzen wie
weit Peking noch gehen wird
ich glaube für den Präsidenten gigi-ping
ist es jetzt erstmal sehr sehr wichtig
Stärke nach innen bei seinen Landsleuten
zu zeigen denn das letzte Jahr ist doch
sehr sehr schwierig für ihn gewesen die
Wirtschaft läuft nicht gut und der Grund
dafür ist seine nullcovid
corona-strategie das hat das Land und
die Wirtschaft lahmgelegt und viele
Menschen leiden und sind deswegen auch
sauer und nun kommt eben dieser Besuch
von Nancy Pelosi vorher hat ja Präsident
Ski eine rote Linie gezogen hat gesagt
über die dürfen die Amerikaner nicht
drüber gehen sie haben das getan und nun
sieht der Präsident doch ziemlich
schwach aus deswegen diese massiven
Drohgebärden und auch der Abbruch quasi
fast mit diplomatischen Beziehungen
allerdings glaube ich dass Präsident
Schiers nicht zum Äußersten kommen
lassen wird also ein militärischen
Konflikt mit Amerika dafür hält er sich
nicht stark genug aber alles unter
diesem Level wird jetzt gezogen und wird
durchgezogen und das heißt es gibt sehr
frostige internationale Beziehungen
immer was hat denn etwa der Stopp der
klimagegespräche mit China jetzt für
ganz konkrete Folgen für die USA und
auch für die Welt
ja beide Seiten haben ja überraschend
beim Klimagipfel in Glasgow letztes Jahr
vereinbart dass man zum Beispiel mit
Tangas gemeinsam reduzieren will haben
man hat eine Arbeitsgruppe gegründet da
will man Technologien gemeinsam
entwickeln miteinander austauschen und
die große Frage ist jetzt eben ob das
erstmal nur ein Stopp für die Gespräche
ist für diese Arbeitsgruppe oder ob
China sich komplett aus diesen
Vereinbarungen verabschieden will das
wäre natürlich schlecht für die ganze
Welt denn nur wenn die USA und China an
einem Strang ziehen in dieser Frage dann
motiviert das eben auch andere
mitzumachen und das versucht Washington
jetzt eben Peking zu vermitteln dass der
Schaden viel größer ist als die
Aufregung ist eigentlich wert ist über
eine politikerreise nach Taiwan und dann
einmal steht natürlich eine Frage immer
im Raum wie groß ist denn aus US sich
die Gefahr dass bei all diesen
militärischen Säbelrasseln im Moment
etwas außer Kontrolle gerät
das ist gefährlich auf allen Ebenen
normalerweise gibt es Gespräche zwischen
dem Befehlshabern dem Pentagon hier in
Washington und im chinesischen
Verteidigungsministerium in Peking da
sagt man sich gegenseitig welche Manöver
man vor hat man redet über Bedenken um
eben Risiken auch zu senken und wenn das
nicht mehr stattfindet gerade in so
einer Situation wie jetzt wo sich
Kampfpiloten von beiden Seiten
amerikanische und chinesische Kampfjets
auch taiwanesische Kampfjets in der Luft
begegnen und einer vielleicht das Gefühl
hat er wird angegriffen und überreagiert
dann kann das ganz schnell dramatische
Folgen haben insbesondere eben weil die
Kommandeure eben dann auch keinen
direkten unmittelbaren Kontakt zu ihrem
jeweiligen gegenüber haben und dann
gehen wir noch nach Peking Ulf wissen
die Sichtweise auf Deutschland aus China
jetzt hat sich der
Menschenrechtsausschuss des Bundestages
ja angekündigt für Ende Oktober zu einem
Besuch in Taiwan
eigentlich ist die Sichtweise auf
Deutschland relativ positiv wenn wir bei
unseren drehreisen unterwegs sind und
sagen wir kommen aus Deutschland dann
ist das meistens ein Türöffner die
Chinesen lieben deutsche Produkte und
auch die schädliche Regierung hat bisher
keine Kampagne gegen Deutschland
gestartet was Sie zum Beispiel bei
Amerika gemacht hat aber dadurch dass
die Kritik jetzt aus Deutschland immer
lauter wird an China eben auch an den
Menschenrechtsverletzung und auch an dem
engen Verhältnis das China mit Russland
hat gibt es eben immer verstärktere
Kritik der chinesischen Regierung und
vor allem solche Reisen wie angekündigt
jetzt aus Deutschland das ist eigentlich
ein bisschen die Urangst von Chichi Ping
das jetzt ein reisetiplomatie nach
taiwat entsteht dass wenn er unbedingt
verhindern und deshalb macht er das was
China immer macht es droht mit der
stärksten Waffe die es hat mit der
Wirtschaft und hinsichtlich Deutschland
heißt das für China sehr einfach wenn
die Deutschen schon Angst haben vor
einem kalten Winter wegen des russischen
Gases dann sollen sie sich schon gar
nicht mit China pflegen weil dann wird
es richtig kalt und das ist das stärkste
Argument und auch bei dieser Frage muss
man sagen werden wahrscheinlich die
deutsche chinesischen Verhältnisse in
Zukunft ja im wahrsten des Wortes
frostiger sehr interessanter Analyse
ganz herzlichen Dank an unsere
Korrespondenten in Washington und in
Peking Elmar Olf vielen Dank
nach Deutschland dieses Land ist ja
mittlerweile weltweit bekannt dafür
große Bauprojekte mit peinlicher
Verspätung und atemberaubender
Kostenexplosionen abzuschließen wenn sie
denn irgendwann tatsächlich
abgeschlossen werden
Terminals für flüssig Erdgas
installieren und ans Netz anbinden so
ein Projekt dauert bis zu acht Jahre
wenn alles glatt geht aber acht Jahre
Zeit hat Deutschland nicht um eine
drohende Energiekrise zu meistern und
deshalb sagen Bundesregierung und
Niedersachsens Landesregierung jetzt es
muss in zehn Monaten gehen und haben die
Vorbereitungsarbeiten offiziell begonnen
heute obwohl noch viele Fragen offen
sind aus Wilhelmshaven berichtet
Elisabeth Schmidt
Franz Josef kissing erinnert sich noch
ganz genau daran als der Anruf aus dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium kam am 8
März war das zwei Wochen nach dem
Russland die Ukraine angegriffen hatte
würdet ihr die Gasleitung bei
Wilhelmshaven bis Jahresende hinbekommen
wurde seine Firma gefragt das war eine
spannende Woche es hat ja tatsächlich
nur eine Woche gedauert also vom ersten
Anruf einen Plan machen gucken geht's es
ging und jetzt machen wir die offizielle
Baugenehmigung liegt noch gar nicht vor
sie wird in zwei Wochen erteilt hofft
kissing trotzdem vorbereiten 100.000
Tonnen Sand und Schutt kommen auf Ecker
und wiesen die Baustraße darf bereits
aufgeschüttet werden es ist ein Kampf
mit der Zeit dem Wetter und mit
Lieferschwierigkeiten
wir hatten eine Insolvenz einer Firma zu
verkraften
die für uns wichtige Bauteile bislang
immer hergestellt hat
das sind die großen Hürden gewesen
ansonsten war die Unterstützung durch
die Bevölkerung in diesem Projekt durch
die Behörden und durch die Politik
exzellent das kennen wir auch anders in
Deutschland
1.500 massive Stahlrohre jedes neun
Tonnen schwer und in Salzgitter
hergestellt sollen am 22 Dezember schon
unter der Erde liegen und die gut 26
Kilometer lange Erdgaspipeline bilden
läuft alles nach Plan verbindet die
Leitung das schwimmende flüssig-erdgast
Terminal in Wilhelmshaven mit dem
Gasnetz Tanker bringen dann LNG zum
Terminal allein über diesen einen
anleger konnten pro Jahr 20% der
russischen erdgas-lieferungen ersetzt
werden es hätte schon viel früher soweit
sein können
wir haben uns lange ausgeruht und wir
haben 2019 dieses Projekt schon mal
geplant und es ist damals auch am
Widerstand in der Region gescheitert
weil der Eindruck war wieso wir haben
doch das russische Gas obwohl wir die
Annektierung der Krim hatten obwohl wir
hätten viel schlauer sein müssen in der
Frage sind wir nicht zu abhängig andere
Länder sind deutlich weiter spanien hat
bereits sechs flüssig erdgasterminals
ein siebtes wird gerade gebaut in keinem
anderen EU-Staat gibt es mehr Spanien
ist bereits unabhängig von russischen
Lieferungen Deutschland muss jetzt
bodengutmachen im Raum Wilhelmshaven
mussten 130 Parteien Eigentümer und
Landwirte dem Pipelinebau zustimmen
einige erhalten hohe
Entschädigungszahlungen egal im Mai
peitschte die Bundesregierung das LNG
Beschleunigungsgesetz durch dadurch
wurde die Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung
ausgehebelt Naturschützer hatten gerade
mal eine Woche Zeit Einspruch zu erheben
egal aber nicht allen
es gab einen 400 seitigen Umweltbericht
um denen überhaupt nur durchzulesen plus
viele andere Gutachten und Kartierungen
die ist da gegeben hat so ist es nicht
möglich vernünftig mitzuarbeiten damit
wird im Prinzip Jahrzehnte positiver
Entwicklung in Natur und Umweltrecht in
Deutschland oder auch ja was auch
europaweit gilt einfach über Kopf
gehauen streng geschützte Schweinswale
schwimmen hier in der Bucht sechs
gefährdete Vogelarten nisten im
Weltnaturerbe Wattenmeer pipelinebauer
kissing verspricht bestmöglichen Schutz
für Tiere und Pflanzen doch die
Energieversorgung der Menschen sie gehe
jetzt vor
und auf ZDF heute.de finden Sie einen
Themenschwerpunkt zur Energiekrise unter
anderem mit Grafiken zu dem aktuellen
Füllstand der Gasspeicher und der
aktuellen Auslastung der Pipelines und
den Überblick über die weitere
Nachrichtenlage an diesem Freitag ist
auf Freitag oder hast du jetzt Hanna
bereits zum zweiten Mal in wenigen
Wochen
haben wir dann Putin und der türkische
Präsident Erdogan getroffen heute in
Sotschi dabei einigten sie sich laut
Kreml unter anderem auf eine engere
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und die
Türkei erklärte für russisches Gas
künftig in Rubel zu zahlen auch der
Krieg in der Ukraine war Thema mit Blick
auf den Getreide Deal zwischen Russland
und der Ukraine bedankte sich Putin für
die türkischen Vermittlungen heute
morgen waren drei weitere
getreidefrachter aus ukrainischen Häfen
ausgelaufen
nach der Kritik von Amnesty
International an der militärtaktik der
ukrainischen Armee die Zivilisten
gefährde hat Präsident selenski die
Menschenrechtsorganisation scharf
angegriffen Amnesty wolle die
Verantwortung vom Angreifer auf das
Opfer verlagern die
Menschenrechtsorganisation hatte der
Ukraine in einem Bericht vorgeworfen die
Bevölkerung in Gefahr zu bringen indem
es Truppen in Wohngebieten stationiert
Israels Streitkräfte haben im
Gazastreifen den Militärchef der
extremistischen
Palästinenserorganisation islamischer
Jihad getötet bei mehreren Luftschlägen
der Israelis kamen nach
palästinensischen Angaben mindestens
zehn Menschen ums Leben über 50 wurden
verletzt die Angriffe galten nach
israelischen Angaben Militärbasen und
Mitgliedern des islamischen Jihads die
Angriffe auf Israel vorbereitet haben
sollen am Abend dann die angekündigte
Vergeltung aus dem Gazastreifen in
Richtung Israel abgefeuerte Raketen die
aber abgefangen werden konnten
das Erzbistum Köln ist von einem
Missbrauchsopfer auf ein Schmerzensgeld
von
725.000 Euro verklagt worden laut dem
Anwalt des Klägers ist es
deutschlandweit die erste derartige
Klage gegen die Kirche als Institution
der 63-Jährige Kläger ist in den 70er
Jahren als Messdiener hunderte Male von
einem Pfarrer missbraucht worden der
mittlerweile verstorbene Priester habe
die Taten zugegeben ab 2014 durfte er
keine priesterlichen Aufgaben mehr
ausüben
der Brand im Berliner Grunewald konnte
zwar mittlerweile größtenteils
eingedämmt werden doch der Sprengplatz
bereitet den Einsatzkräften Probleme der
Boden ist laut Polizei bis zu 700 Grad
heiß und es besteht die Gefahr weiterer
Explosionen mit neu gelieferter Technik
konnten sich die Einsatzkräfte dort
heute ein Bild der Lage machen der
Bereich wird mit Wasser gekühlt
was muss man für ein Mensch sein wenn
man Eltern die ihr Kind bei einem
Schulmassaker verloren haben über Jahre
das Leben zur Hölle macht indem man
wieder besseres Wissen behauptet alles
sei nur eine Inszenierung gewesen
Alex Jones ist so ein Mensch er ist in
rechtsradikalen Kreisen der USA sehr
einflussreich er hat damit Millionen
verdient jetzt hat er vor Gericht
zugegeben seine Lügen sein ein Fehler
gewesen der schlimmste Amoklauf der
US-Geschichte an einer Grundschule in
Connect sei zu 100% tatsächlich passiert
Alex Jones muss den trauernden Eltern
jetzt 4,1 Millionen Dollar
Schmerzensgeld zahlen und das ist erst
der Anfang es könnte das wirkungsvollste
Mittel sein gegen die die mit frei
erfundenen verschwörungsgeschichten Geld
machen und Politik Claudia Bates
berichtet
meinen Sohn gab es ich bin eine echte
Mutter nie hätte Scarlett Louis gedacht
dass sie von diesen einfachen Wahrheiten
mal jemanden überzeugen müsste aber Alex
Jones geht es nicht um Wahrheiten
sondern um Meinungsmache das
Schulmassaker von Sandy Hook mit 20
Toten Kinder habe nie stattgefunden es
sei eine Inszenierung gewesen die Eltern
Schauspieler ein geheimes Komplott der
Regierung um den Amerikanern ihre
Schusswaffen wegzunehmen dass der Vater
seinen erschossenen Sohn im Arm hielt
sei eine Lüge
ich finde keine Worte dafür was für eine
Hölle die letzten Jahre für mich waren
die ich und andere ertragen mussten
wegen der Fahrlässigkeit und
Rücksichtslosigkeit von Alex Jones
der wirkte im Gericht verblüfft dass er
offenbar an einem Ort war wo es einen
Unterschied macht ob man lügt oder die
Wahrheit sagt die Richterin wie es ihn
darauf hin dass er unter Eid stehe und
dies hier nicht seine Show sei im
Kreuzverhör ließ der Opferanwalt dann
eine Bombe platzen
vor zwölf Tagen haben ihre Anwälte etwas
verbockt sie haben mir eine digitale
Kopie geschickt von allen
Textnachrichten die Sie von Ihrem Handy
geschickt haben in den letzten zwei
Jahren
da wusste Alex Jones er hat ein Problem
denn die Nachrichten belegen auch dass
er vor Gericht unter Eid gelogen hatte
Jones Fans hatten die Eltern der toten
Kinder seit Jahren bedroht und belästigt
jetzt musste der klein laut einräumen
ich glaube dass Sandy Hook passiert ist
ein schreckliches Ereignis
aber Alex Jones hetzt weiter ob über
Corona oder die Lüge das Donald Trump
die letzte Wahl gewonnen habe Alex Jones
ist dabei und verdient damit zig
Millionen der preist Fanartikel an und
sagt er brauche das Geld jetzt mehr denn
je nun hat er Insolvenz angemeldet so
erreicht er das weitere Verfahren gegen
ihn zunächst aufgeschoben werden der
opferanwald hofft trotzdem dass die
Millionenstrafe ein Zeichen setzen kann
wenn die Botschaft die unterschiedlichen
Medien dieser Welt erreicht nicht nur
Alex Jones die Botschaft das könnt ihr
nicht machen mit Privatpersonen ihr
Leben zur Hölle machen und bewusst Lügen
verbreiten die euren Zielen dienen
und es werden wohl nicht die letzten
Millionen sein zu denen Jones verurteilt
wird doch ihn beeindruckt das nicht noch
heute schwört er niemals aufzuhören
[Musik]
er will nicht aufgeben ob all diejenigen
die dem verschwörungsmoderator alles
glaubten was er in seiner Show
verbreitet jetzt noch mal nachdenken
weil ihr Idol selbst zugibt zu lügen es
wäre wirklich zu hoffen
wenn der fünf größte Ölexporteur der
Welt ein Drittel seines eigenen Benzins
vom Nachbarn kaufen muss wenn das
Stromnetz bei bis zu 50 Grad im Sommer
immer wieder ausfällt wenn die
Öleinnahmen sprudeln wie selten zuvor
aber ein Teil der Bevölkerung nur mit
Lebensmittelhilfe überlebt dann ist das
Zeichen für unfassbare Korruption und
dafür das generell viel schiefläuft der
Irak hat aktuell keine Regierung dafür
aber eine veritable Staats- und
Wirtschaftskrise und Angst vor einem
neuen Bürgerkrieg Brigitte Saar und
kamransafiarian Berichten
Karim ist Lehrer arbeitslos und mit
einem Freund mehr als 200 Kilometer
gefahren um beim Freitagsgebet im
Regierungsviertel in Bagdad dabei zu
sein
die Hunderttausende Iraker heute bei
singen der Hitze für Karim und alle
anderen hat das Freitagsgebet auch eine
politische Botschaft
ich bin heute hier für alle Iraker all
die die keine Arbeit haben unser Land
befindet sich seit Jahren im Stillstand
[Musik]
er ist Karims Hoffnungsträger und der
von Millionen Irakern mortada
einflussreicher schiitischer geistlicher
er hatte die Wahlen im Oktober gegen
eine ebenfalls schiitische Allianz um Ex
Ministerpräsident almaliki gewonnen doch
keines der beiden Lager konnte eine
Regierung bilden als die Wahl Verlierer
um einmal Leki nach der Macht greifen
ruft als zart seiner Anhänger zum Sturm
auf das Parlament auf zarts Anhänger
wollen verhindern dass die alte
politische Elite wieder nach der Macht
greift bis heute Belag an seine Anhänger
das Parlament als er hat selbst fordert
ein radikalen Neuanfang und droht seinen
Gegner
wird es kein Platz mehr geben so Gott
will es ist eine friedliche Revolution
im Rahmen eines demokratischen Prozesses
erst muss das Parlament aufgelöst werden
dann brauchen wir Neuwahlen
seit fast einem Jahr befindet sich der
Irak in einer politischen Krise ein
Viertel der 42 Millionen ihrer aka leben
unter der Armutsgrenze er will das
ändern mochte als Saat Sohn einer
Gelehrten Familie er gilt als
Nationalist Anwalt der einfachen Leute
er mobilisiert Millionen im ganzen Land
und mehrere 10.000 schiitische
milizenkämpfer folgen ihm sie kämpften
bereits gegen die US-Truppen im Irak
wofür steht als satra er will den Irak
beherrschen und er will dass der
iranische Einfluss im Land reduziert
wird und sein wichtigster Programmpunkt
mit dem man auch punkten kann das ist
sein Kampf gegen die Korruption der Irak
ist eines der korruptesten Länder der
Welt geworden seit der amerikanischen
Invasion im Jahr 2003 sadda selbst ist
durchaus an dieser Korruption beteiligt
jetzt droht ein erbitterter Machtkampf
unter den verfeindeten schiitischen
Lagern im Irak beide haben tausende
bewaffnete Anhänger
da stehen die sehr sehr
nationalistischen also irakischen
nationalistischen Leute um Markt gegen
Iran Treue Kräfte im Lager des
ehemaligen Ministerpräsidenten Maliki
und das noch nicht einmal die ehemals
unterdrückten Schiiten hier im Land eine
gemeinsame Basis finden das zeigt doch
wie stark fragmentiert das politische
System des Landes ist und wie schwierig
es sein wird im Irak in den nächsten
Jahren einen auch nur halbwegs stabiles
System herzustellen noch ist das
Parlament blockiert ein Bürgerkrieg wäre
fatal denn von der Stabilität im Irak
hängt auch die Stabilität der ganzen
Region ab
der nur noch geschäftsführende
Premierminister übrigens hat zu Ruhe und
Mäßigung aufgerufen vergeblich
Beobachter sagen sein größtes
Vermächtnis dürfte sein dass er seine
Amtszeit überlebt hat
hier bei uns in der Sendung noch mal
Hannah ja mit einem Thema bei dem sowohl
Verbraucher
als aas-umlage kommt so will es
zumindest die Bundesregierung und das
wird sich voraussichtlich ab Herbst
schmerzlich in den Portemonnaies
bemerkbar machen jetzt wird geprüft ob
die gasumlage von der Mehrwertsteuer
ausgenommen werden kann Stefanie Barrett
in Frankfurt was würde das genau
bedeuten ja das kann man sich leicht
ausrechnen auf die gasumlage Kim im noch
mal 19% Mehrwertsteuer drauf
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner will das
eben vermeiden und prüft jetzt alle
Möglichkeiten um die Mehrbelastung der
Bürger abzuwenden laut EU-Recht ist
Energie aber eben
mehrwertsteuerpflichtig und die
Bundesregierung muss nun eben erstmal
rechtlich sehen ein Weg finden um die
gasumlage von der Mehrwertsteuer
auszunehmen im Gespräch ist ja eine
Spanne zwischen anderthalb und fünf Cent
pro Kilowattstunde das hängt letztlich
davon ab wie sich die Gaspreise
entwickeln und vor allem wie viel Gas
ersetzt werden muss bis Mitte August
soll die genaue Höhe errechnet werden
dann könnten beispielsweise auf einen
pärchenhaushalt zwischen 214 und 714
Euro im Jahr zukommen auf den Rechnungen
wird hier gasumlage allerdings erst im
November oder dezember zu sehen sein was
aber wohl nur ein schwacher Trost sein
dürfte ja die Belastung ist hoch für
Verbraucher und Industrie da gab es
heute noch mal deutliche Kritik welche
genau ja Kritik der Industrie entzündet
sich an der ungleichen Lastenverteilung
90 Prozent der gasumlage sollen ja von
Verbrauchern und Unternehmen geschultert
werden 10% müssen die Energieversorger
allein tragen hier sieht die Industrie
noch Nachbesserungsbedarf um nicht nur
Verbraucher vor existenzgefährdenden
Rechnungen zu schützen sondern auch eben
die Unternehmen trotz allem von der
energiefront gibt es heute aber eine
gute Nachricht die Gasspeicher erfüllen
sich und nähern sich der magischen Marke
von 75 Prozent die bis Ende des Monats
erreicht werden soll das deutsche
Aktienbarometer dagegen gab heute zum
Wochenschluss nach auf Wochensicht
verbuch der DAX aber immerhin ein
kleines Plus danke Stefanie für diese
Einschätzung
der Ball rollt wieder in der ersten
Bundesliga hat heute die neue Saison
begonnen mit dem Spiel Eintracht
Frankfurt gegen Bayern München seit
wenigen Minuten ist die Partie zu Ende
Bayern hat sechs zu eins gewonnen
es gibt eine aktuelle Unwetterwarnung
des Deutschen Wetterdienstes vor
schwerem Gewitter mit heftigem
Starkregen Sturmböen und Hagel in Teilen
von Baden-Württemberg und Bayern
südkorea hat erstmals eine eigene
Mondsonde ins All geschickt eine Falcon
nein Rakete der privaten Raumfahrt Firma
SpaceX brachte dann Nuri wieder Orbita
heißt planmäßig ins All bis Mitte
Dezember wird die Reise zum Mond dauern
den soll dann Nuri dann umkreisen Daten
sammeln und herausfinden wo auf dem
Erdtrabanten eine Landung möglich ist
denn das ist eines der Ziele von
Südkoreas Raumfahrtprogramm
zurück auf der Erde war das unsere Welt
an diesem Freitag danke ihnen fürs
Interesse und unser heute journal Update
gibt es heute gegen
4 fit Kristoffer Wehrmann von uns allen
hier an sie einen angenehmen Abend
tschüss
[Musik]
willkommen etwas Regen gab es heute an
dieser Kaltfront die zu diesem Tief über
Skandinavien gehört die kalt von schiebt
sich jetzt in den Südosten Deutschlands
schleift dann etwas an den Alpen entlang
dahinter macht sich aber schon wieder
ein neues hochbreit wir gehen aber noch
mal zurück zu Kaltfront die sich heute
Nachmittag schon über das Land legt und
für 19 Grad in Cuxhaven sorgte während
es vor der Front noch richtig heiß war
mit 36 Grad in Regensburg und diese
Mischung sorgt dafür dass es aktuell in
dieser heißen Südosthälfte noch teils
kräftige Gewitter gibt und das geht
jetzt in der Nacht auch erstmal so
weiter von Berlin-Brandenburg bis an die
Alpen Schauer und Gewitter die größte
Unwettergefahr gibt es dabei im Donau
Umfeld und südlich davon mit
hagelschweren Sturmböen und Starkregen
der teilweise über mehrere Stunden
anhält also vorsicht hier vor
Überflutungen dann kühlt es in der Nacht
noch ab und der klaren Himmel auf 8 Grad
in der Gewitter Luft auf 18 Grad Morgen
haben wir dann nicht mehr so ein
deutlichen Temperaturunterschied da gibt
es 19 Grad an den Küsten und angenehme
27 Grad am dazu beruhigt sich das Wetter
auch südlich der Donau ist es zwar noch
stark bewölkt es gibt aber nur noch
vereinzeltschauer und Gewitter sonst
viel Sonne und nur lockere Wolken und
mit diesem Hochdruckeinfluss geht es in
den nächsten Tagen dann weiter das
bedeutet aber auch dass kaum mal wieder
ein Tropfen Regen fällt es gibt viel
Sonne vor allem im Norden auch hier und
da mal ein paar Wolken insgesamt ist es
aber nicht mehr ganz so heiß bei 20 bis
32 Grad das war es von uns das Wetter
Team wünscht einen schönen Abend